hi I'm Eric Voss and I really really
love the movie Wonder Woman it's so
great walk into a new superhero movie
and just be like yes they got it right I
can't wait to spend hundreds of dollars
on sequels and team-up movies and
cosplay and I think I can pull off a
Wonder Woman romper anyway in this video
I'm going to go through the whole movie
and break down every little detail that
shows why this was a great movie Easter
eggs influences from classic films
history mythology interesting visual
choices and this should go without
saying but yeah spoilers ahead go watch
the movie spend money on it so they keep
making Morgan movies like this alright
go go go okay let's get started with the
opening images of the movie as the
camera swoops in from a cloud covered
planet Earth two overhead shots of
present-day Paris we hear this
interesting voiceover from Diana I used
to want to thank someone beautifully but
the closer you get the more you see the
great darkness within so the camera
moving into Paris like this reveals
Diana's cynical perspective as this
movie begins the planet is covered in
clouds masking its true nature with
diana doubting whether it's even worth
saving remember this opening scene takes
place probably shortly after the events
of Batman vs Superman when Diana was
still pretty skeptical that mankind had
any redeemable qualities and the goal of
this movie is to take Diana back into
her memories who remind her of the time
that she was first inspired by the
courage of mankind and once we get to
the Louvre there's a reference to that
darkness simmering within mankind the
Dark Knight himself with this Wayne
Enterprises truck and right away we get
our first possible Easter egg here let's
zoom in on that license plate Jael 8 to
8 dzm now some people are saying that
Jael could be a reference to Justice
League with the numbers referring to
Superman issue 82 which is the issue
that Superman Returns so maybe this is
the hint that in Justice League those
little pieces of dirt won't be the only
things riding out of Superman's grave or
we can look at the rest of the numbers
and letters on the plate and just assume
this is all random but that's not what
we do here we're paranoid nutjob okay
moving on the story goes back in time to
Diana's youth on sim it's Kira now as we
were watching the scenes you might have
wondered how exactly this all-female
society works like without men how do
they know anything about reproduction
really
the amazonian don't need men just like
in the Wonder Woman comics Diana is
crafted from clay and all the Amazonians
aged very slowly the director patty
Jenkins clocks adult Diana at 800 years
old in this movie and that makes it
super interesting coming-of-age story
for Diana like when we first meet her
she's a wide strong Renaissance woman
she's already a superhero but in this
story she's more of a fish out of water
with her naivete coming from leaving
this pastoral utopia where women can do
whatever they want to a different
dirtier more patriarchal civilization
and for me one of the more interesting
parts of this movie was Hippolyta
bedtime story two young Diana explaining
the history of the Greek gods in the
Amazonian and I really love patty
Jenkins choice to convey this in a
visual style similar to Renaissance
painting Greek mythology was actually a
very common theme for Renaissance
artists so Jenkins used a visual
reference from art history to make the
Amazonians feel part of our world as
well and keeps missus during the
sequence Hippolyta mentions how mankind
at one point enslaved the Amazonians
leading to Zeus giving them their own
hidden paradise and this could be a
reference to Hercules from The Wonder
Woman comics Hercules also known as
Heracles isn't really a good guy in the
comic like Hippolyta beat him in a
battle but then she offered to feast him
and his men as a token of goodwill but
then Hercules drugged her and steals her
girdle and enslaved all the Amazonians
nice going Hercule okay moving on to
Diana as an adult played wonderfully by
the wondrous gal gadot isn't she a
wonder there's a cameo hereby boxer and
wolf
she plays Artemis she's the badass
warrior who takes a hit to the back and
then tosses the other warriors she's
also the last warrior that Diana beats
before taking on Anne typing now Diana
bracers here are so powerful because
they're actually made from the broken
pieces of the aegis that's the shield
that's carried by Zeus and Athena and
Greek mythology so it's the power of the
Gods that allows her to blast away and
Taichi and all the others here then we
need Steve Trevor played by Chris Pine
who's painfully funny in this movie I'm
sorry he grant this was playing the
waters outside the island and Diana
rescuing him underwater and smiling down
on him on the beach is your shot-by-shot
homage to the sequence in the Little
Mermaid when Ariel saves Prince Erik
from the shipwreck honey Jenkins
actually listed the Little Mermaid and a
few other films as influences for this
movie
I'll get to those when we come to and
then when the German soldiers arrive
notice how the name on their ships is
the SMS schwaben the Schwaben was
actually a real-life world war one ERA
ship and fun fact in 1905 it were placed
to ship called the SMS Mars which is the
Roman name for Ares the main villain in
this movie now I love this beach battle
sequence it was one of the most
beautifully choreographed battles I've
ever seen in a superhero movie but
besides the amazing leagues and swing
the big reason why this scene works so
well is that were emotionally engaged
with it through the eyes of a character
notice how Diana hardly participates in
this fight instead it's all shown from
her perspective behind the rock she
witnesses the strongest warrior she's
ever known fall victim to bullets
according to patty Jenkins that was all
by design really every action sequence
is from probe point of view and for her
story she witnesses a battle on a beach
that rocks her world and changes for
understanding of what warfare is okay
moving on to speeds interrogation using
the lasso of truth which gets a new name
in this movie the lasso is Hestia in
Greek mythology Hestia is the goddess of
the hearth family and domestic life
which is interesting because it's like
this movie is implying that the honesty
forced out by the lasso is kind of a
foundation for a family structure also a
little history here the creator of the
original Wonder Woman comics William
Moulton Marston also went on to invent
the systolic blood pressure test which
was a key component in the polygraph so
I guess it's guys kind of obsessed with
people telling the truth tells the truth
and then notice the interesting design
of these Thrones these golden spirals
reflect the shape of the lasso also
there are contrast to the normal
straight edged Thrones that we normally
see instead the circular spiral reflects
the never-ending immortality of the
amazonian and then Steve's confession
takes us back to his mission on the
Ottoman base now this movie takes place
during World War one which of course is
different from one woman's origin in the
comics which is during world war two now
somebody were saying that's because we
already saw a period piece superhero
origin story in World War two with
Captain America the First Avenger
but how did Jenkins actually said that
World War one was the first time
civilization as we know it what's
finding its roots but not something that
we really know the history of Jacob
called it a mechanized war where you
don't see who you work
and those concepts of military
industrialism and death on the mass
scale are big parts of this movie we
also made the main villain general erich
ludendorff who was actually a real-life
german historical figure but his
character in this movie seemed more
based on the Duke of deception from the
Wonder Woman comics he was an agent of
Ares who tricks one a woman into
thinking that he's Ares also he inhales
these gas capsules to give him
superhuman strength and I could see DC
cinematic using this specific tech as
the point of origin for other DC
characters maybe Bane if they ever
decide to reboot him as a character we
also meet doctor Maru dr. Poisson who
seems pretty closely adapted to the
version in the early one woman comics
even hinted that the characters eye mask
with these goggles that she wears on the
top of her head I also appreciate the
design choice with the World War One era
a smash the cover a chemical burns and
realized many wounded soldiers actually
wore masks just like these you may know
the character from Boardwalk Empire
Richard Harrow wore something very
similar but in addition to this history
Jenkins said that she also pulled from
retro adventure movies like Indiana
Jones and watching this old daring
escape by Steve Trevor definitely feels
like it could be lifted directly from
one of those movies like making out with
a book and shooting up the place with a
stolen plane okay moving on we get to
see more of Diana and Steve chemistry in
this bath scene and then later on the
boat and then Diana says here that she
learned about sex by reading all 12
volumes of Cleo's treatise on body and
pleasure no that's probably not
referring to Miss Cleo infomercial
fortune teller called now Steve Trevor
and I'll show you a position that'll
blow your mind free loyal and Greek
mythology cleo is one of the muses the
muses are daughters of Zeus and
goddesses of the arts and cultures Leo
is actually the muse of history so the
subtle implication here is that the
Amazonians look at sex so
matter-of-factly something that you'd
read in like a history textbook
I guess my history textbooks did have
some pretty pornographic doodles thrown
in on public school okay moving on to
London it's not a set designers did such
a good job transforming the city into a
polluted war zone specifically to
heighten the contrast with the mascara
like Diana needs to experience that
shift into a society that's obsessed
with war specifically know this war
propaganda poster on the wall behind
them kitchen is the key to victory eat
less bread this
was a real poster printed during World
War one to boost morale on the homefront
as all food was directed to the
frontlines and this idea of a
top-to-bottom war economy is so foreign
to Diana not mention the image of a
woman in the kitchen but then next we
meet edit candy she see secretary just
like she is in the comics and during
this shopping montage I really like this
line Oh like she's not the most
beautiful person in the world now this
has to be a reference to Superman the
idea that glasses could make him
completely unrecognizable but speaking
of Superman according to patty Jenkins
that movie was also a major influence
specifically this fight scene the alley
is a recreation of the scene of
Superman's when he extends his arm in
front of Lois to block the bullet and
catch it actually Chris Pine said that
him shaking his hands and pain here is
another reference to Indiana Jones and
those fight scenes also a lot of people
are comparing Diana's flex pose here to
another iconic propaganda poster Rosie
the Riveter like Wonder Woman Rosie went
on to become an icon of female
empowerment okay fast forwarding past
all these scenes at British intelligence
and it's quickly got to give some love
to Chris Pine comedic delivery here its
timing the facial expressions as they
wrap the lasso of truth around its wrist
perfectly grounds all the magic and
mythology that Diana brings in the movie
I'm taking you to the front terrible
idea next we meet Steve's motley crew of
fighters including Sameer now this isn't
explicitly said in the movie but Sameer
is part of the Blackhawks
which was an old DC comic that also came
out during World War two it's about a
group of pilots and commandos of mixed
nationalities now when the team departs
in the Kings Cross train station in
London there's a quick moment when Diana
tries ice cream for the first time and
loves it and tells a guy that he should
be proud now this exact exchange is in
the new 52 comics as well as in the
animated movie so you should be very
proud of this achievement and speaking
of the comics I already mentioned the
original William Moulton Marston version
but the modern depiction of Wonder Woman
was created by George Perez in 1987
reboot if you look closely the credits
you'll see that Paris actually received
a prominent thank you okay moving on to
the war front the team is smuggled in by
chief who is a Native American so
between chief and Sameer and Charlie the
idea here was to expose Diana to a
diverse group of men to show that this
wasn't just a war fought among them
Americans and Europeans but a truly
world war and the filmmakers also made
the smart choice to not shy away from
the psychological horrors of that war
world war 1 was considered one of these
first wars that people began to realize
that soldiers were taken more home with
them so it's important for Diane to see
that Charlie is suffering from PTSD in
the form of night terrors and anxiety
notice how the camera also lingers on a
returning soldier who's literally
suffering from shellshock
all of these little moments are designed
to build Diana up to a boiling point on
the frontlines in the trenches wherein
she's tired of being told that she can't
do anything about this and real quick
aside here apparently there's a cameo in
these trenches by Batman for Superman
and Justice League director Zack Snyder
he's somewhere in the background dressed
up as a soldier but I haven't been able
to spot him anyway moving on to the big
moment
Diana climbing out of the trenches and
out into no-man's land this is such a
powerful chill inducing image like the
idea of reimagining a past war with a
super heroic figure who just says screw
this I'm going to do something this is a
big part of why movies like inglorious
basterds and the first Captain America
works so well and Wonder Woman really
pulls it off here and like the beach
battle earlier the viewer is emotionally
invested in this battle because it stays
with Diana's point of view as the
characters that he'd taken said this to
say about it and then she comes to man's
world and she sees a war that everybody
says is impenetrable and nothing can be
done about it and she says what am I
going to do about it and let's be honest
a big part of the excitement of the
sequence is the music and actually
there's a whole secret super interesting
origin story behind the composition this
music the meaning behind it how Hans
Zimmer and the other people who worked
on the music of this film came up with
it and I made a whole other video that
goes deep into that so go check it out
when you get a chance okay then
Diana's rescue of the occupied town of
bells is also so well executed like she
lives and flips the armored car which
could be a reference to the 2001 Wonder
Woman comics Spirit of Truth where she
lifts a tank also notice how the team
ends Steve uses a chunk of metal as a
shield to launch Diana into this people
to take out the sniper which is the same
move that Steve saw and Taiping used in
the beach battle earlier so in a way
Steve is honoring Diana's on showing her
that he remembers and has learned from
the
Amazonians world okay moving on when
they celebrate the liberation of elves
he jokingly refers to the Mistura as
Paradise Island now that's the reference
to the original name of Diana Toma in
the comics it was referred to as
Paradise Island throughout the Marsten
run until Paris rebooted it and came up
with the name famous Kyra later there's
another fun miserable reference to
Wonder Woman history as they sneak into
German High Command Diana steals her
blue dress from this fuzzy blonde German
lady who's listed in the credits as
false to graybles
in the comics graybles was a Swiss not
the operative who tried to capture
Wonder Woman but she's kind of more well
known from the 70s TV show where she has
similar blonde hair as in this movie and
I don't know about you but when Diana
was like staying next to her size in her
up I kind of half hoped that we would
cut to the gala and just see Diana
walking in wearing this woman's skin
like ah this I can fight so I faked it
then later when Ludendorff tragically
gasses the town of El this is another
key moment that reveals the real horror
of World War one an estimated a hundred
thousand to two hundred and sixty
thousand civilian casualties were caused
by chemical weapons blowing into nearby
towns and villages and even though no
direct strikes of this kind were
reportedly ordered there is historical
evidence of soldiers knowing that the
poison gas might affect local women and
children but not being concerned because
they were still targeting the enemy and
again this horror is an important step
and Diana's growth in this movie like
later after she kills Ludendorff
thinking he's Aries she sees that the
soldiers are still mobilizing weapons
anyway and she learns that mankind is
inherently flawed outside of divine
influence so it makes her decision to
fight for them that much harder for her
but I gotta say I was pretty impressed
with the reveal of the real Aries in
this film it's Sir Patrick played by
David Thewlis here he plays a spin on
the classic mustachioed villain like if
you look back on the movie his offer to
run the operation and secret out of his
office was really just an attempt to
keep tabs on their whereabouts and then
when Steve was talking to Sir Patrick on
the phone Diana concludes at that moment
that Ares is Ludendorff but she was so
close to the real answer Ares was on the
other end of the phone call there's a
couple of miscible references that come
up in the scene with Ares first when
Diana ties him up in the last of truth
Ares says I am the god of truth and this
seems like it could be a reference to
the comic specifically the god killer
arc of Gail Simone and
Chang's one-woman series when Ares says
war its truth and creepily LIXIL a so
then Ares shows Diana a surreal vision
of the Paradise that he wants to build
after wiping out humanity in this moment
is parallel to that scene in Man of
Steel when Zod tries to tempt Superman
by showing him an illusion of his post
Humanity world next this emotional
farewell between Steve and Diana on the
airstrip is an homage to another classic
film that patty Jenkins mentioned
Casablanca is looking at you kids but
just like how that alley scene was a
reversal of a Superman theme this is
also a reversal in this version the guy
leaves on the plane now sees sacrifice
flying on the plane carrying the gas
canisters and detonated it out of harm's
way seems like it could be a nod to the
end of The Dark Knight Rises which makes
me think that maybe Steve could have
ejected at the last second and
parachuted down somewhere like I think
we need to get Lucius Fox in here to
check that planes autopilot
oh it's World War one and airplanes
don't have autopilot or ejection seats
oh he did moving on the Armistice Day
celebration in London includes the field
little Easter Egg next to Steve's
photograph in the Memorial there are
photos of real-life British War poet
siegfried sassoon and Wilfred Owen their
poetry actually brought to light the
psychological toll on soldiers returning
from war I just say that Sassoon didn't
die in that war though he died in the
60s so it's a little weird that his
photo is up on this memorial and that
brings us to the closing images back in
the present day Diana writes back to
Bruce thanking him for bringing Steve
back to her and this trip down memory
lane was what Diana needed to enlist her
into this next World War the war for
this world which we'll see in Justice
League and banked in the final seconds
for this movie is listen closely you can
hear a boom in the distance followed by
sirens leading Diana to suit up and dive
in a battle this could be the arrival of
Darkseid and this pair of demon army and
it's possible that Justice League will
open on Diana in the middle of this
battle and this brings me to a lingering
question for you guys did Wonder Woman
live up to your expectations
like do you agree with all the great
reviews in the praise that this is the
best DC cinematic movie or did that hype
raise your expectations a little too
high let me know what you think in the
comments so this video has an amazing
sponsor and I'm so excited about them
then I'm going to
do this shout out as Miss Cleo now this
video was brought to you by our friends
at birth but it's a really great service
that pulls together a ton of great
content channels like crunchyroll
Funimation roosterteeth mundo pasted and
cartoon hangover all you got to do is
download the verve app on your
PlayStation Xbox Roku iOS or Android
device
where you can watch a ton of great stuff
great anime which comes subtitled or
double tight end season 2 and even Miss
Cleo can't predict what's going to
happen next there I also enjoy shows
like Adam Savage's one day build Adam
Savage I tell your fortune you'll keep
busting those Miss Honey
well there's a really amazing service
just go to a BRB dark or slash go
premium just start a free 7-day trial
honey and I want to keep this
conversation without Wonder Woman going
like I have a ton of thoughts about it I
want to make more videos about it but
it'll help to do that if you comment
like this video share it subscribe the
new rock stars you can more directly
help us make more videos like this and
have a say and what those videos are by
contributing on patreon thanks so much
to all of our current donors especially
my man Chris Cal tweet your thoughts
about Wonder Woman to me at EA boss or
follow new rock stars on Twitter at new
rock stars for updates on our videos
okay thanks for watching bye